Deine Identität, dein Name, deine Bilder – eingesetzt von Betrügern, um illegal an Geld zu kommen.
"Kriminelle nutzen die Corona-Krise für ganz
neue Betrügereien."
Betrüger greifen Privatpersonen an, Unternehmen,
ganze Staaten.
Verbrecher wittern ein großes Geschäft mit
der Corona-Krise.
Der Gesamtschaden: Noch nicht genau zu beziffern.
Doch es geht um viel Geld.
Auch wir werden angegriffen und bekommen eine
Phishing-Mail.
Wir drehen den Spieß um und wollen herausfinden:
Woher kommt die Mail, wer sind die Betrüger?
Wochenlang bewegen wir uns in verdeckten Foren
im Internet.
Treffpunkte von Kriminellen.
Es herrscht Goldgräberstimmung.
Die Verbrecher attackieren auch uns online:
Wir bekommen eine E-Mail auf unsere Arbeitsadresse.
Angeblich vom Arbeitgeber zdf.de.
Darin werden wir aufgefordert den Anhang zu
öffnen. Was würde passieren, wenn wir sie
wirklich öffneten?
Von Berlin aus sprechen wir mit einem IT-Spezialisten
in München.
Werner Thalmeier,
Technologie-Chef Europa, Proof-Point
Wir haben Fälle, wo sich die Angreifer in
aktive Zahlungsvorgänge mit einklinken Das
heißt, die Überweisung geht dann nicht auf
das Konto von dem Geschäftspartner, sondern auf
irgendeine Bank, wo sie dann auf Nimmerwiedersehen
verloren ist die Zahlung.
Haben die Angreifer das bei uns versucht,
wollten sie in unsere Bankverbindung eingreifen?
Wir wollen wissen, woher der Angriff kommt.
… Thalmeier verspricht, die Email zu analysieren.
In der Zwischenzeit versuchen wir, dorthin
zu gehen, wo die Kriminellen sind – in die
Tiefen des Netz, das sogenannte Deep-Web.
Wer Zugang hat, findet einen digitalen Untergrund-Marktplatz.
Im Angebot Drogen, Waffen und geklaute Kreditkarten
– die Verkäufer agieren wie Geister, nicht
sichtbar.
Versteckt hinter Krypto-Technik reden sie
über Betrugsmaschen in Corona-Zeiten.
Wir schreiben viele Forennutzer an, wollen
besser verstehen, wie der Betrug funktionieren
soll.
Einer antwortet.
Sein Deckname: Fillingtempel.
-
...
Fillingtempel stellt Konten zur Verfügung,
mit denen andere die Herkunft von Geldern
verschleiern, die sie meist illegal erwirtschaftet
haben.
Das Geld landet also auf gefakten Konten – angelegt
mit Hilfe geklauter Identitäten.
DIe Betrüger nennen das Bankdrops.
Wie funktionieren diese Fake-Konten?
Nach langen Vorgesprächen ist ein Cyberkrimineller
bereit uns zu treffen. Anonym, in einem Hotelzimmer.
Er erklärt, wie sie an die Identitäten der
Opfer kommen.
Wir schalten Fake-Webseiten mit Jobangeboten.
In den Jobangeboten haben wir bei der schriftlichen
Bewerbung um Einreichung des Ausweises gefragt
angeblich für die Erstellung eines Arbeitsvertrags.
Und so habe eine seiner Seiten ausgesehen
– hier wird ein Screenshot des Personalausweises
abgefragt.
Cyberkrimineller, ohne Insert
Mit diesen Daten wird dann der Bankdrop erstellt.
Das heißt: Wir erstellen so ein Bankkonto
und verwalten das unter deren Namen, ohne
dass sie davon wissen.
In Deutschland können Online-Konten nur noch
mit einem sog.
Video-Ident-Verfahren eröffnet werden.
Die Betrüger manipulieren diese Verfahren.
Wenn man die Leute dahingehend bearbeitet
die Video-Ident-Verfahren zu machen, da gibt
man sich als jemand aus, der man gar nicht
ist.
Die Betroffenen haben lange keine Ahnung,
dass ihr Konto dazu dient, kriminelles Geld
zu waschen.
Meist fliegt der Betrug nach 4 Wochen auf.
Es lohnt sich offenbar trotzdem.
Unser Informant beziffert den Schaden, den
er angerichtet hat, auf rund 2 Millionen Euro.
Er sei 2019 ausgestiegen, als seine Gruppe
ins Visier der Fahnder geriet.
Wollten Betrüger auch an unsere Kontodaten?
Unser IT-Experte Thalmeier aus München hat
unsere E-Mail analysiert.
Die Rückschlüsse, die wir aus dem Angriffes
Muster ziehen können, ist, dass diese Gruppe
eine semiprofessionelle Bande ist, also eine
kriminelle Gang, wenn man so will.
Thalmeiers Analyse zeigt: Die Angreifer agierten
mit einer portugiesischen IP-Adresse.
Und: Wir sind nicht die einzigen potentiellen
Opfer.
3600 Menschen gerieten ins Visier der Kriminellen.
Die Coronakrise ist ein willkommener Anlass
für Cyberkriminelle, schnelles Geld zu verdienen.
Sie versuchen von der Unsicherheit zu profitieren.
Auch unser Kontakt Fillingtempel ist offenbar
involviert.
Er schickt uns ein Chatprotokoll.
Er und ein Unbekannter tauschen sich aus wie
die Corona-Abzocke ablaufen soll.
Fillingtempel soll für die Täter Geld waschen
– und das möglichst schnell, bevor Öffentlichkeit
und Behörden es bemerken.
7 Tage nach diesem Chat ist klar, worum es
ging: "Offenbar haben Betrüger eine Masche
gefunden, die Soforthilfen vom Staat abzukassieren."
"Tausende Anträge seien missbräuchlich
gestellt worden."
Fillingtempel schickt Fotos.
Sie belegen: Es wurde tatsächlich Geld an
ihn überwiesen: 9000 Euro.
Absender ist Corona Bezirksregierung Düsseldorf
Und so soll der Betrug gelaufen sein:
Die Staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt.
Zum aktuellen Verfahren keine Auskunft.
Oberstaatsanwalt Markus Hartmann bestätigt
aber, dass Kriminelle so vorgehen wie unser
Kontakt Fillingtempel es beschrieben hat.
Die Kriminellen gehen arbeitsteilig vor - die
einen programmieren Fakeseiten, andere - wie
unser Kontakt Fillingtempel - stellen die
Bankkonten zur Verfügung.
Bestimmte Fachrichtungen, kann man fast sagen,
spezialisieren sich auf das Entwickeln von
Schadsoftware, die nächsten auf das Anbieten
von Bankkonten, über die Zahlungen geschleust
werden.
Die dritten haben besondere Fachkenntnisse
der Webseiten Programmierung und über Marktplätze
im Internet, vorallem im Darknetbereich finden
dann diese unterschiedlichen Spezialisierungen
zusammen und ermöglichen damit vielfach auch
erst eine professionelle Tatbeteiligung.
Wie viele Millionen der Corona-Hilfen von
Kriminellen kassiert wurden, wird sich erst
in den nächsten Wochen zeigen.
Ein Ende der Masche scheint nicht in Sicht:
Fillingtempel meldet sich ein letztes Mal:
Mittlerweile wurde bekannt: Betrüger haben
auch in Sachsen, Berlin und anderen Bundesländern
Soforthilfen abgezockt.
Wart ihr schon mal betroffen von Cyberkriminalität?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare!
Frontal - ab sofort erscheinen hier auf dem
YouTube Kanal von ZDF heute Nachrichten regelmäßig
unsere Recherchen.
Abonniert den Kanal, um keine zu verpassen.